so certainly as an associate director
clinical development I helped to develop
drugs medicines that are important to to
the community the global community I
manage large trials what we call phase
three trials in essentially the medical
managing and monitoring of these studies
I and several other clinicians are
responsible for and we develop
strategies and on how to you know
improve some of our drugs or strategies
on how to manage new trials you know and
so that we can have these medicines
available to the community to the people
of patients that need so that definition
essentially what I do here advisor but
you know I almost cannot separate what I
do also from the philanthropy slide
because it's also an extension of my
work here in philanthropy you know I you
know amongst with with the rest of my
team you know help make these medicines
available to people that need it and not
just advisor but all the companies you
know I'm giving us their products to
distribute to communities that have need
for it so you know one way you know in
one job and helping develop these
medicines and then in the other job you
know I'm helping to provide these
medicines that we've developed to the
community so it's it's a win-win and and
I enjoy it
you